okay I'm pretty sure I mostly understood
what went on and this one Legion chapter
10 second episode of season 2 and like I
said I pretty much could follow this one
which which is good it season one did a
really good balance of this too and it
seems like so far season two is
maintaining it which is that for every
episode where I'm like I don't know what
I just watched but I'm fascinated by it
I'll guess I'll get one that I don't
want to say is straightforward cuz
that's a leap for this show but is
comparatively easy to summarize so this
is an episode spoilers by the way so
this is an episode where we dig a little
bit more into the idea of David helping
out the shadow king or Farouk I guess
I'll just start calling him that because
that's what they call him most of the
time sort of how that goes not the way
he wants it to go initially some of the
consequences of that him trying to
figure out how to get the best possible
result out of a situation he barely
understands and yeah I could actually
more or less follow this I don't know
how many of the people's heads would go
to this place but I really hope the
whole thing with Lenny and Oliver
breaking in and singing swinging on a
star was a Hudson Hawk reference holy
he's telling me that's what it was no
one else remembers that movie but me I
swear sometimes and we got so apparently
now we've got an actor basically playing
Farooq previously last season we had you
know the yellow-eyed king you know which
was just sort of this thing that looked
good when it was in the background it
got some focus shots later on the season
that where it didn't look so good I'm
glad that's not back however I was
initially very edgy about the the Khan
cept of having a new actor to play this
part cuz I really liked abri Plaza
embodying this character which she did
very well in the previous season but it
does not appear that Lenny is now going
to go away she's still gonna be there
but now being more or less herself as
opposed to having to embody Farouk so
much but she's still around and I expect
her to remain around so I am glad for
that that said I am still I'm probably
gonna be a little bit sad as I expect
the nature of her to change a little bit
she's probably gonna go back mostly they
just being the kind of twitchy character
which we saw a little bit more of this
this episode where as I kind of like to
hide her presence when there was a
balance between the twitchy energy and
then the more sort of calculating nature
of what fruit brought to the table so
you know I still may may be a little bit
sad for for what Aubrey Plaza is called
upon to do for the remainder of this
season but she's not gone so I'll take
it as far as other stuff I'm glad that
Kerri is is okay and they fell I
actually carry a lot I like the whole
concept of that character of those two
characters and yeah I love that it's so
weird and strange and has not really
gotten a proper explanation and I don't
ever want it to so I'm glad that they
that they are alright that was one of my
big tension moments in the preview
season where it seemed like one or both
of them might die so I am quite relieved
for that I feel like we're getting into
David's fractured psyche a little bit
more we got a little bit more of him
with the voices in his head some of
which were very clearly the thoughts of
someone he was talking to others of
which seemed to just be himself kind of
yelling in his own head about something
in either case it was wonderfully
distracting especially where he's got
that scene where Oliver his wife whose
name was now escaping me for some reason
where she's you know talking about
something and he's just
you as the audience you can't you don't
actually you missed a whole chunk of it
because the voices in his head kind of
dominate and so we're getting a bit more
of that with him right now which again I
think is a good direction to go
especially because if nothing else it
gives a little bit of a grounding to the
insanity the whole concept would the is
another character his name is now
escaping me at the moment the guy with
the basket on his head and and all of
his moustache lady secretaries or
whatever they are who sound like GLaDOS
from Portal again I don't know what's
going on there but it's so weird I kind
of love it I'm just I'm really glad that
I could follow this episode better than
I could the previous one because
honestly after that first episode for
the second season I was worried that
trying to do reviews for these episodes
was just gonna be an exercise in I don't
know and it's still even now kind of is
because I only came to know what this
episode but they're having something a
bit more coherent I feel like I can't
actually talk about it if this second
episode have been as abstract and nuts
as that first one there'd be a fair
chance that instead of giving a review
I'd be putting out a video explaining
why I'm not gonna keep doing previews of
the show because I don't know how to
review these episodes but I don't think
that's gonna be necessary but this man
this show is so crazy and it's funny
because you know there are there's a
couple of people I know who are
recommend this show like everybody and
I'd absolutely do not there or there are
people whom this is forget impenetrable
it'll just be infuriating but for me
it's just the right level of what the
hell was that this is nuts
so yeah I guess that's about it for
second episode of
I'm really curious to see how things
move forward how much is David getting
played with what he's doing and or does
he realize that and he's not letting on
who knows but obviously this whole
alliance is gonna go super bad it's just
a question of at what point that happens
and now of course we've also got the
hint of something way worse than Farouk
way worse than the Shadow King and you
just left gonna wait a minute what and I
will be really curious to see what that
ends up being
I suspect that'll be another nice little
x-men Easter Egg of some nature but yeah
there's there's so many yeah like I was
gonna say there's so many ways for this
to go but I did that even that's unfair
like I literally have no clue where you
go from this and which is often the case
with with Legion that just makes me
enjoy it all the more I don't know how
you continue from that but I want to see
Legion season 2 episode 2 did you see it
what were your thoughts on it whatever
they are drop something down the
comments let's talk about it there's all
the stuff to do such as support me on
patreon and help make the show better
potentially he and you know I'm on
Twitter and I've got a podcast and
there's t-shirts etcetera etcetera
etcetera links for all that stuff is
down in the descriptions don't until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]